[Musique]
bonjour à toutes et à tous et bienvenue
dans ce nouveau numéro de ski mag
transports en commun véhicules
individuels circulations douces la
mobilité représente un enjeu majeur de
la vie quotidienne synonyme de liberté
d'accès à l'emploi de développement
économique elle répond à des impératifs
multiples sur le territoire saint
quentinois
la mobilité est en perpétuelle évolution
alors quels sont les derniers
changements à l'oeuvre bus tram voitures
vélos véhicule autonome ont fait le tour
c'est parti
[Musique]
je suis obligé de prendre des transports
en commun les bus les trains rer je
prends toujours le train bon je pense
que c'est plutôt bien desservie au
départ me plaindre c'est très bien
desservi on a de la chance d'être dans
une région c'est assez bien desservi il
ya toujours un train du formation c'est
normal mais je trouve toujours qu'un
train améliorer les trajets du quotidien
en développant des solutions au service
de tous
tel est le but du plan local de
déplacement instauré sur saint quentin
en yvelines
le doublement du pont guy schuller à
maurepas l'enfouissement de la rn10
attrape la rénovation du pouls de la
ville dieu ou encore le développement
des pauses gars sont parmi les projets
impulsés le service de mobilité a
souhaité donc faire un bilan de quatre
années de réalisation de ce pôle
d'excellence et donc en 2014 et qui
court jusqu'à 2030
il ya eu 137 actions qui figurent dans
ce dans ce bld dans six thèmes qui sont
les transports en commun les modes
actifs la circulation automobile
le stationnement les marchandises est là
et la communication est tout d'abord le
ferroviaire place au pôle gare et à la
multimodalité la verrière plaisir
grignon villepreux les clés ces trois
garçons concernés par des réaménagements
à la verrière le projet comprend le
réaménagement des parvis la construction
d'une nouvelle gare routière et d'un
parc relais évolutif de 750 places 150
stationnement supplémentaires pourront
être ajoutés en cas de besoin à la gare
de plaisir grignon le réaménagement est
à l'étude
à terme les espaces publics seront
repensés ainsi que les voies d'accès et
les parkings à la gare de villepreux les
claies le contrat de paul prévoit le
déploiement de la multimodalité mais
aussi la requalification du parvis avec
la mise en accessibilité complète de la
station
[Musique]
tout comme à la gare de montigny le
bretonneux d'ici 2024 date des jeux
olympiques 268 gares franciliennes
devrait voir leur accessibilité
améliorée à la gare de saint quentin en
yvelines
un ascenseur et deux trottoirs roulants
relieront les quais 1 et 2 à la
passerelle surplombant les voies et la
ligne 18 dans tout ça la ligne 18 du
grand paris express devrait relier la
future gare saint quentin s à guyancourt
aux autres grands pôles de développement
d'île de france mais aussi aux
infrastructures de transport cette
fameuse ligne 18 dont on a besoin pour
relier les saint quentinois re à la plus
grande université française qui est en
train de se créer à toutes les belles
des entreprises aussi caraïbes au
laboratoire sur très important c'est le
projet par les sectes et le projet a été
maintes fois négocié annulé réenvisager
avec l'état alors se fera ou ne se fera
pas c'était
bien entre guillemets au congélateur
donc là il semblerait qu'il ait remis au
frigidaire je ne dis pas qu'il est sur
la table mais il semble qu'une
amélioration
s'il était validé le projet de la ligne
18 devrait être envisagée pour les
jo-2020 tu 4 le réseau de bus se
renouvelle aussi plus de lignes de
meilleure rotation aux heures de pointe
et le week-end et des bus connectés
après une vaste enquête auprès des
habitants et des salariés pour connaître
leurs besoins l'agglomération à adapter
son réseau de bus
nous avons aussi travaillé bien sûr à la
réorganisation du réseau bus sur
l'ensemble du territoire avec des
résultats plutôt positifs puisque sur
certaines lignes la fréquentation a
doublé
on a sur certaines lignes renforçaient
déjà créé une belle ligne qui
n'existaient pas créé des lignes fortes
surtout dans notre dans notre secteur le
secteur nord de saint quentin parce que
nous n'en avions pas est également
l'amplification des horaires puisque
nous avons des bus plus tard le soir ce
qui correspondent vraiment à des
attentes et le week-end les lignes
express reliant l'agglomération à l'île
de france ont aussi été renforcées
offrant plus de courses comme la 475
entre la clé de saint pierre et la porte
d'orléans deux quarts à étages devrait
être mise en service d'ici l'été en
juillet prochain le pôle d'échangés
multimodal de versailles chantiers sera
mise en service la ligne 439 sera
prolongée entre versailles rive gauche
et versailles chantiers
autre nouveauté trois bus électriques
ont été inaugurés en mars dernier une
nouvelle technologie qui s'ajoute au
système des dalles exploitation et
d'information des voyageurs
sans oublier l'application via go d'ici
fin avril
elle permettra depuis son smartphone de
connaître le trafic en temps réel
en combinant tous les modes de transport
[Musique]
autre bouchon récurrence du compte 10 ou
leurs deux ans de travaux viennent de
s'achever pour y remédier ces images ne
devrait plus être pour les
automobilistes qu'un vilain souvenir
en février dernier la transformation du
conte guy schuller a été inaugurée après
vingt mois de travaux
l'un des plus grands chantiers réalisés
ces dernières années sur l'agglomération
en fait il y avait énormément de
l'embouteillage d'encombrement et qui
générait non seulement de la pollution
ce mais surtout surtout les retards
d'énormes retards pour l'ensemble des
usagers de la sncf qu'ils savaient
qu'ils pouvaient pas compter sur la
régularité des bus même ceux qui
venaient en voiture se trouvait bloqué
donc il était plus que temps de faire ce
doublement du pont schuller nous allons
construire sur à côté de la gare un
parking de 750 places avec une
possibilité d'extension à 900 places
malgré l'augmentation de population
malgré l'augmentation de fréquentation
nous ne souhaitons pas voir
l'augmentation de trafic donc ce pont
c'est le transport en commun en site
propre qui partira d'ici qui va jusqu'à
la gare de trappes
nous mettons un accent particulier dans
le développement l'aménagement le
renforcement des l'ensemble des
circulations douces sur l'ensemble de
l'agglomération et plus particulièrement
basses été l'occasion de faire quelque
chose de parfaitement adaptés et pour
les piétons et pour les cyclistes
ici sur le pont fuller
qui dit route d'une voiture et sécurité
routière petit tour d'horizon des
aménagements piétons vélos voitures afin
que chacun cohabitent en toute sécurité
certains aménagements ont été réalisés à
guyancourt trappe et voisins des zones
30 ont été créés intersection
accidentogène identifiés et formant des
masques de visibilité supprimer pose de
ralentisseurs
côté sanctions des radars ont été
installés pour répondre aux
comportements dangereux
afin de parfaire sa connaissance en
accidentologie l'agglomération s'est
doté d'un logiciel pour mieux analyser
les problématiques et sécuriser les
routes
[Musique]
de son côté la bicyclette prend du
terrain un nouveau schéma de pistes
cyclables est actuellement à l'étude
celui ci devra s'étendre aux douze
communes
[Musique]
je me déplace beaucoup en vélo et en bus
j'ai battu donc surtout vélo et vélos et
bus ça fait travailler les muscles en
même temps qu'on se déplacer parfois
c'est même plus rapide que le bus si les
trajets sont pas trop longs dès que je
peux j'utilise le vélo c'est plus
pratique
une chaude et piscicoles donc c'est
assez rassurant je trouve topal très
pratique parce que il ya quasiment
partout sauf comme a quand même pas mal
ça c'est facile de se déplacer en vélo
il ya toujours un coin pour les vélos
encore pour les piétons et encore pour
les vêtir 400 km d'itinéraires cyclables
dont 150 dédié au vélo à saint quentin
en yvelines et la petite reine pourrait
encore s'étendre grâce au choix que la
france a fait pour les jeux olympiques
de donner quatre sites olympiques
saint quentin en yvelines dont trois
sites vélo donc c'est un accélérateur
pour saint quentin 2 du plan de mobilité
douce
on a déjà 400 km de pistes cyclables
donc on va intensifier jusqu'à 2024
actuellement à l'étude un diagnostic
étudie la façon dont tout le territoire
pourraient être reliés par ces pistes
cyclables et notamment au nord avec
toutes les difficultés que ça peut
comporter
parce que nous ne sommes pas à
construire ce modèle d'une ville
nouvelle
mais on était plutôt des villages et
avec des voies qui sont pas forcément
d'un gabarit facile pour la fois avoir
de la circulation du stationnement et
des pistes cyclables des choix devront
donc être opérée en attendant ce mode de
transport séduit et pas seulement au
sein de la vélostation de la gare
saint-quentinoise bientôt des vélos
électriques supplémentaires devraient
être fournies par la région pour
répondre à la forte demande
quant à l'idée de trottinettes
électriques elles restent envisagées
dans un futur proche
[Musique]
dernier projet mobilité en date des
navettes suspendu et autonome
fonctionnant 24 heures sur 24 et 7 jours
sur 7
le projet supra ways est déjà en route
elles pourront transporter jusqu'à sept
voyageurs sans conducteur elles
fonctionneront à l'énergie solaire et
électriques 7 jours sur 7 24 heures sur
le passager pourra commander sa navette
via son téléphone portable
le projet supra ways issu d'une certaine
lyonnaise est la dernière innovation en
date pour faciliter la circulation sur
l'agglomération
c'est un projet qui est très intéressant
parce que il nous permettrait vraiment
de faire des liaisons sans avoir à
prendre voilà les voitures avec un débit
de navettes autonome très très rapide
c'est un très beau projet c'est un
projet se met à rien donc très très
moderne et puis c'est du transport avec
individualisé puisque avec votre
portable vous pouvez commander une
navette et il vous rend très rapidement
d'un point à un autre
navettes électriques n'ont pas de
pollution c'est le même système
d'intelligence que les navettes autonome
les navettes se suivront toutes les cinq
secondes en station soit près de 3600
personnes par heure contre 4000 par
heure pour un tramway sur saint quentin
en yvelines
l'étude de faisabilité a déjà été
effectué bien sûr il ya tout ce qui est
sous sol et cetera pour poser les
piliers mais également comme on longe la
base de loisirs
dans des recommandations qui sont très
strictes entre autres il ya une réserve
de croix de triton et qu'il faut pas
déranger et c'est donc il a fallu que le
projet s'adapte à l'endroit où sont les
traitons et assurer leur tranquillité le
projet initial desservira les communes
de montigny le bretonneux trappe et
l'encours et plaisir les stations seront
implantées en gare de saint quentin en
yvelines au futur polski high tech en
passant par les sites retenus pour
accueillir les épreuves des jeux
olympiques et paralympiques 2024 dans un
futur proche saint quentin en yvelines
pour est inauguré un autre type de
transport innovant travail sur la
voiture autonome et on va bénéficier des
premières expérimentations ou what you
ton billet déjà eu d'ailleurs à saint
quentin les voitures tonnes qui sont
dans l'année où les ai pas vues mais et
pas de chauffeur regardez bien connu une
voiture vous d'où le mène donc on est
partout voitures bus train
vélo
et puis eux
transports se mit à rien d'envoyer mais
quand même le paquet
[Musique]
ce qui m'agace c'est fini à très bientôt
pour de nouvelles aventures
saint-quentinoise ciao
[Musique]